a big loss of all the SMP one of the
party's best known most experienced
faces but perhaps not a huge surprise
for a number of reasons firstly Ian
Blackford is 62 by standing again you
need to commit to being in Parliament
until he was 68 secondly he's already
reached the top he's been the leader of
their Westminster group was leader for
five and a half of the eight years he
has been in Parliament thirdly he was of
course deposed from that position got
rid of by his own MPS last December and
finally he lives far far from
Westminster he represents Ross sky and
lock Harbor lives on the Isle of Skye
and getting home after a week in
Parliament involves a flight to
Inverness and then a three and a half
hour drive by car to the Isle of Skye
where he has a small farm I've spoken to
him a couple of times this afternoon
he's also released a short statement
here is some of that a statement Mr
Blackford said with the s p selection
process for the next Westminster
election taking place over the coming
weeks I have thought long and hard about
whether to offer myself as a candidate
again having stood down as s p
Westminster leader I've gone through a
period of reflection as to how I can
best assist the party and the cause of
Independence a cause I've campaigned for
since joining the SMP as a teenager in
the 1970s although I won't be standing
for the western department at the next
election I look forward he says to
playing my part in the continuing
campaign for Scottish independence and
supporting our first Minister and the
SMP as we go forward to the next
election and Beyond I understand Mr
Black will continue with a role working
with the Scottish government on business
and economic policy he has been a
significant figure joined the party in
the late 70s so it's been a member for
almost 50 years although briefly was a
member of Scottish labor fell out with
Alex salmon in the late 90s early 90s
more recently been very close to
Nicholas sturgeon but Sarah Jane there
has been this generational change in
that party with Ms sturgeon sounding
aside of course this announcement does
prompt one question what happens in Ross
sky and locaba that constituency
formerly held by Charles Kennedy the
late liberal Democrat at leader
certainly s p sources have told me
there's no
will win it but it will be one to look
out for when it comes to next year's
general election